un cyril bonjour vous êtes notre envoyé
spécial en vous retrouver ce matin à
kiev vous êtes depuis
déplacez vous êtes à quelques kilomètres
donc de de la capitale un ce dernier
verrou qu'on évoquait à l'instant et
repine où l'offensive russe semble-t-il
s'accentue
effectivement le som avec georges
lévesque je dois passer le pont virpi
qui est effectivement les titans de tous
les combats il ya perte ans est reparti
riz des bombardements pendant que j'en
parle les forces russes de dire tu
craignais qu'on est au
100 mètres de là on se trouve exact un
bus intra vol d'oiseau en direction de
cbc les immeubles qui sont le pavillon
du pin est là devant moi des blessés qui
sont en fait il ya un pont jusque
doutons pas c est un pompier tesco 38
heures les forces du craignait non
justement prévenir cette offensive sur
rouleau compresseur
on sent vraiment ici il ya des fumées un
peu partout de là où je pose mon hangar
les fumée noire qui s'élève des pillages
d'hier pin de bouchain là on est le
nord-ouest de kiev qui est sous d'assaut
russes il ya donc de multiples
bombardements et cet endroit est
absolument apocalypse totalité des pays
il ya des voitures abandonnées criblés
de balles et ce pont maintenant détruit
devant moi j'ai des familles notamment
avec des animaux des photos des sticks
tout ce qui faisait la normalité de
cette vie chrétienne il ya encore moins
de dix jours et bien qu'ils s'apprêtent
à passer des pieds dans l'eau sous ce
pont par un quai improvisé il ya aussi
énormément de volontaires armés nous
avons pu être passé un peu de temps avec
un légionnaire français régional un
membre de la légion étrangère
l'ukrainien qui a déserté il faut le
dire qu'il va totalement il n'avait pas
de scrupules à déserter il est là il a
traversé la france avec sa voiture quand
m pendant neuf jours pour arriver à la
frontière polonaise rentrée en du cannet
il se bat ici avec eux son arme ça fait
six jours qui tient ce souffle il a dit
je me battrai je suis très bien
sûr étrangères ont fait partie de ces
volontaires d'étrangers qui sont ici
nous avons pu également rencontrer un
membre un habitant de dire pin qui
faisait l'aller retour
parfait c'était un ancien trader il a
dit que les russes effectivement
s'attendre à l'avancé il ya des tirs
d'artillerie très important qui continue
que les combats de d'effectifs sur plus
important corps qui est en constant ici
c'était vraiment une zone de dévastation
et c'est vraiment une zone de guerre aux
portes de pièces et je rappelle qu'ici
c'est le nord-ouest deux tiers de la
capitale italienne un des derniers
endroits où l'on pouvait passer il
dresse maintenant certainement plus au
sud c'est donc ça me donc et tout le
monde en est totalement conscient et là
j'ai devant moi des personnes âgées
qu'on essayé d'extraire en fauteuil
roulant on sent bien que cet exode c'est
parce que plus personne ne croit que tu
n'y vas pas y voir le fait de quelques
chaque cuillère au plus vite des
fondements de cette ville d'ottawa du
nord-ouest qui sous bon barbecue
important de porter russe dans la région
de kent merci beaucoup cyril payen
échanger asbeck qui vous accompagne pour
ses précieuses informations évidemment
faites attention à vous